you have it has to be it has to be
success or nothing
and right and i i was going to be a
dentist i was going to go to dental
school i got my degree in biology and
you know you're going to be a dentist
left that behind
i didn't have a plan b anymore it was
like okay so this is i don't
you know what if i don't if i don't make
it i'm not gonna
i don't i don't know what else i'm gonna
do um and so i never really had a plan b
so i had to figure out how to make it
work
and um i remember peyton manning said
something about that one time he goes
you know i think he was a choice between
denver and
another team and they said how do you
know you made the right choice he goes
what if you make the wrong choice
because i'm not going to make the wrong
choice because i'm going to make this
choice work
that's sort of that's sort of the
mentality that you have to have or that
i've had to have because
and i still do i don't have anything
else i have to make this work
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show we have the
writer director actor of buddy games
josh demelle we we're very similar in
that we're
we're midwestern kids he's from north
dakota i'm from illinois
so it was fun to kind of talk about that
style of living
and um maybe some of the contrasts
between
there and hollywood and then it was
really cool to get into
movies because i don't nobody about
anybody else out there but i don't
really understand
how they're made and what it takes but
it's really hard and um he explains kind
of the challenges to getting buddy games
made
and then even just the challenges within
acting
you know tapping into characters and
what that takes and what that's like
josh is just a super down to earth
really grounded guy
i mean he's from north dakota what else
do i have to say uh he also has another
show coming out called jupiter's legacy
that's
about a superhero and it's a tv series
that'll be coming out in 2021
so he's a busy guy but he's making time
for slowing down uh at his cabin
in minnesota and you're gonna hear all
about that
so enjoy the show i want to talk about
being an awesome midwesterner
and how you're just a good north dakota
boy
wow that's that's so uh
i am i am from north dakota i still i
still claim north dakota
uh even though i haven't i've actually
lived in
california now for more than half of my
life
yeah and it still feels like that's
that's that's home
and i do spend a lot more time there now
than i have in the last 20 years
right mostly because i have a cabin
just on the other side of in over in
minnesota
i i fly into fargo a lot i go back to
minot where i'm from
a lot but i spent a lot of time also at
my cabin which i'd you know especially
during all of this
all this coved stuff i've i just found
a respite there and it's been it's been
it it
really sort of helped me keep my sanity
i was just out there in the woods by
myself
with my son my dad and just people that
i love friends family whoever
and so that's really where my heart is
most of the time la right now is tough
because you just can't do anything
so i agree and i actually think that
part of you know something nice that i
had
this year was that i wasn't in la very
long like i ended up
leaving la in june and so not
being in there not being there for all
the drama and
there's a lot of energy there and it's
not always the most calm energy
so i can totally uh relate to that i
went back to indiana
so similarly like just a quieter town
but my mom's side of the family is all
from the border of minnesota canada so
they're from russia
i know roso good hockey up there yeah
either oh yeah so i'm so familiar i've
been to fargo flown into like
um what's on the border is it
international
falls international falls is right on
the border it's in the same minnesota
are you talking about
minnesota right yeah yeah but i've flown
in i'm trying to think like where the
baby was yeah oh been driven through
bemidji many times when we were kids
those are like my fondest memories
is driving up through sometimes we go
through minnesota sometimes we go
through wisconsin
and up through bemidji and then you only
knew you had three hours left once you
passed bemidji
okay so so you're from roseau no my
mom's
my mom's from there your mom's from
there okay yeah so you know the cold
weather
oh i know it well oh yeah yeah like it
does not
phase me it doesn't bother me um
it feels so you know the seasons are
great
i mean they they really there's there's
like a a reason for the season too
there's
you know um you know up and up in that
area they call it snow cats
snowmobiling oh yeah i just bought two
of them by the way like last week
yeah how many cc's uh well i knew you
were going to ask me that of course you
would ask me that
i'm not quite as uh daring as you are
danica so i got i got
i got six hundreds i didn't get i didn't
go with the eight
well listen my friends who are hardcore
snowmobilers all like you gotta get the
850s
like i'm not looking to go 175 miles an
hour on my snowmobile
last time i was on it i flipped it so
i'm just i'm easing my way into it
so i bought i bought uh i bought a
polaris uh
switchback 600 and i bought uh a polaris
indie adventure which is like a 550 kind
of like a workhorse so i can
you know i can go ice fishing with it i
can pull the kids around on you know
sleds and stuff like that so you know if
i go out and need to gather some wood
for the fire i can just
take that out there and pull it back in
the slide it's just like
so normal i think of that as being so
normal and that's that's part of the
reason why i love it out there honestly
i mean
for i grew up in north dakota and we
grew up outside of
minot which is about 10 miles out and
and it was
it was like in the country all day long
i was just like catching frogs and
turtles and
you know salamanders and whatever
whatever we could find
and so i and so this has been kind of
like going back to my childhood in a lot
of ways just to be able to get back out
get back in touch with nature because i
feel like i'm most at peace when i'm
out there doing the basic stuff like
chopping wood
or you know changing tires on the
on the lawnmower that goes flat every
year or whatever you know i'm just out
there doing things i never
i have a little i have a yard here in la
and everything's done like i don't i
don't even have a tiny little yard and i
don't i've never mowed it
i go back to my cabin i mow and i cut
like acres of lawn and cut new trails
and i'm just out there doing stuff
but i don't i don't know what it is but
something happens when i get out there
it's like a different person shows up
and when i come back here it's like
i mean i miss it i'm not able to do the
same stuff i'm able to do out there
are you comfortable in l.a like do you
feel like yourself
well i'm comfortable with the work side
of it because
i've been doing it now for a long time
and i love
i love what i get to do but as far as
the
you know the lifestyle no it's not
really for me
but this is where i kind of have to be
in order to you know do what i
do for a living so i found a nice
balance between going back and forth
um the the kid in me the the the nature
boy
that that i grew up as sort of comes
roaring back every time i get out there
what do you do for fun in l.a then like
what would be
what makes you feel a little like a kid
or a little like home
what do i do here um other than work
what do you do i you know i don't go to
the clubs
i don't really go out we go dinner um i
golf a little bit
um you know i'm mostly just raising my
seven-year-old son
you know here and that's pretty much it
uh you know he and i do a lot of stuff
i'm teaching him how to golf
i love taking him out to the cabin
because he gets to sort of do some of
the stuff i did growing up
and i think it's important for him
growing up here in la
um but yeah you know we went swimming
today
um we draw a lot he loves to draw
i try to get him to play sports but he's
not really into it yet so we'll see
oh really so he's more of an artist
i don't know i'm thinking it'll kick in
at some point
but yeah right now he's definitely more
artsy than he is
athletic so when you bring him back to
minnesota is that where the cabin is yes
when you bring them back to minnesota
it's just basketballs footballs
baseballs a net a soccer ball
yeah i mean that's that's really i mean
that's the way we grew up
is north dakota there's not a lot to do
especially in the winter
besides play sports so that's all we
really had
uh and and so we would just that's all
we did whether it was ping pong or
you know we'd make [ __ ] up we'd be like
a balloon ball let's play balloon ball
you know you go there we would make
games up
in la it's much different because
there's just so much more to do
you know there's just you know typically
outside of this you know
pandemic uh there's there's just you
know there's a million things that
that kids can do but i think that you
have to have to find something for me
he needs to play some sport because i
feel like you need to be able to
you need to learn how to win you need to
learn how to lose you need to learn how
to be a teammate you need to go through
all those
the struggles the hard work that it
takes to be good at something you know
and it's easy for kids now to sort of
get pampered and end up you know growing
up not having
dealt with anything i don't want him to
go through that
what do you think i was thinking about
you know him growing up in la and you
probably think
i wish he could grow up in minnesota or
somewhere like that
but what do you say i mean i feel like
everyone's leaving l.a
yeah california people are leaving in
it's a mass exodus
[Laughter]
they're getting it they're finally
getting it yeah it's it's
it's it's a great this is it's an
amazing state
i just i disagree with a lot of the
things going on here uh it's not that
it's not being it's not they're not
making it very easy to want to stay
if you know what i mean because there's
there's just there's
there's there's a lot of things that are
sort of repelling people from
realizing they even want to be here
anymore because yeah that you know and
if you want to get into like all i mean
i think this is probably happening in a
lot of big cities right now is that
you know doing what we're doing people
can be as productive
you know doing a zoom calls they could
in person so yeah
therefore is there a reason for some of
these people to be living in big cities
uh it's definitely going to be
interesting when this thing all sort of
blows over
what do you think what's your intuition
well i think
i think it's it's it's good in a lot of
ways because i do think that people are
trying to do kind of what i'm what i
what i'm doing too
is that they're getting back to you know
back to nature back to the basics
they want they want to sort of restart
and start fresh and just
keep it simple you know i think that
we've we've
get so caught up in all the technology
and everything that it makes it
you know and i was i'm the first one
that was doing it i just get caught up
in it all and i don't ever stop to sort
of
look around and i think that this has
given us an opportunity to do that
you know whether it's reconnect with
your family or
yourself or get back into nature just go
you know
do some basic stuff that you haven't
done for years
uh but at the same time it's gonna hurt
these big cities because you know you
look at the way
you know things were run for so long
whether it's you know in an office
building
or you know if you're if you're
commuting from
from you know the suburbs into the big
city to go to your office do your thing
a lot of people are realizing they don't
have to go to the office anymore they
can be as productive from home
so i think it's really there's there's a
big shift that's happening
um and it's going to be interesting to
see how it all kind of settles
after this thing goes away
you actors are going to be or people in
la
with enough pull your contracts may
start to include things like um
you know a salary or
a portion of funds for jets so that you
guys can get back and forth to where you
want to go
so you're like look i actually live over
here so if you want me
look we're gonna need an x amount of
budget for the plane because you know i
i i just i like the idea could you be my
agent
yeah sure you negotiate that for me yeah
i feel like
you know i'm a i'm a boss i'm a boss of
companies and a boss of myself and also
i fight for um uh
you know comfort like i want people when
they're whether they're working with me
or i'm working with them
quality of life quality of life is of
the highest of importance so whenever
i'm doing anything
i'm always asking questions about well
what works for you what's best do you
want to do that earlier do you want to
do that later
maybe you can we can do this here you
can leave early so you can catch the
last flight home it's like
all about quality of life because you
know that's how you have
sustainability well and that's how you
keep people around you happy and wanting
to keep doing a good job
too you know if you're if you're if
you're always dropping the hammer
and people feel sort of
repressed it doesn't necessarily equal
quality of life and therefore they're
not going to work as hard for you as
they probably
you know would you totally working out
of fear out of love or working out of
you know working
working for the love of it it's a really
interesting point because i've worked
i've worked in a lot of those different
situations sometimes
you work you work for somebody who is
you know he he
he he brings the hammer and everybody
works out of fear
therefore everybody's just kind of
trying to save their own ass on set
yeah or you work for somebody who
allows gives people the creative liberty
to go do what they do
and it makes them more creative and i
think it makes the whole process that
much
better in the end that was the way i and
having done this now for i don't know
20 some years and having seen like
really small budget
things and then seeing really big budget
things and how different how you know
how
like taking the best and sort of leaving
the rest
uh is what i could try to what i try to
bring
to you know the set on body games is
that okay i'm gonna i've got these guys
i got a great cast
i've got you know i've got a i've got
a great dp i've got great you know
costume the whole i just made sure i had
great people around me because i knew
that i didn't
know everything i needed to know to do
it that's so smart to know though
oh yeah we just said a lot of no's there
but that's so smart to know that you
don't know
yeah and i knew that i didn't know
enough but i knew that i
didn't have to know everything i just
had to have good people around me that
i would enable to go out and do their
job
so that they would want to they would go
through a wall for me you know
and that's the kind of cr the you know
the environment we tried to create and
even with the actors i was like you guys
you guys are here for a reason we have
you know this scene has to push the
story forward
and this is what we need from it and
then i just kind of let them you know we
try to get was on the page but at the
same time we
you know let them go too and that
is usually where you find the best stuff
what was that i mean obviously i'm
getting the impression that of course
you were
you were the you were the one that was
getting people to work out of love
but i'm stupid because i didn't have any
money we didn't have any money we had
basically worked for free you couldn't
tell them what to do they were like
dude i'm working for free i'm gonna do
this
um that works too um
but well i'm so fascinated by because
i know that it was a long process to get
buddy games made
and um there's a lot of aspects of
making it and what it took and the
intention
and the belief and everything but let's
just start with like
what the hell does it take to get a
movie made oh
it's it's a minor miracle that anything
gets made yeah
i mean i just went through that
firsthand i mean we went through we had
more obstacles than i think
most productions typically have uh
but i mean we started i started writing
this thing in 2014.
that's how long it's been we wrote it
rewrote it rotary wrote it got it to a
place where we
felt comfortable taking it in or taking
it out to the town
took it to um actually one of the first
people we took it to was wwe
because we knew that they were trying to
rebrand their
their studio and not just do movies that
had professional wrestlers but
normal movies and uh michael louise was
the guy that
that was running in the studio at the
time and he
he loved it and he said we love it but
we want to do this and that's then you
go into the rewriting process and he's
like
and then you get in then you have to
start writing for
like cost okay we'd love to we'd love to
jump you know
over the waterfall and down over through
the city and crash through the window
but you know it's going to cost too much
money you got to find another way to do
it
so you know it was the writing and
rewriting that took about a year and a
half
and then it was getting it the money and
then it was getting the cast
and then the shooting of it was all
great so all that stuff probably took me
two year two three years probably to get
it done and in the can
and then uh midway through
uh editing the movie we got
we got uh michael got
let go from wwe he had there's a power
struggle at the top and he got let go so
now my guy who was cheerleading me the
whole time
was gone and then i knew that the thing
was probably going to be in trouble
because the people that were there then
i didn't trust had my back
with it or weren't going to do what he
would like gone the extra mile that he
would have gone
and that kind of turned out to be the
case so i ended up
buying the movie back from wwe
so then i could then because i didn't
because they were just going to sort of
put it out there
and not do with it what i thought it was
going to do because we'd seen it perform
and
we'd put it on screen for a couple test
audiences
and it just killed i mean the people
like lost their [ __ ] watching the movie
and i was like oh my god they think it's
i didn't think people were i didn't know
if people were going to think it's funny
because it was
it's pretty raunchy i don't know if
you've seen it yet but it's pretty
raunchy
and but they they died laughing and i
was like oh my god they think this is
funny
and then so when they were gonna sort of
just put it out
and and just sort of not
put everything they had behind it i
decided that i wasn't
going to let it go out like that and
bought it back from them
that took about another year just the
legalities of all that and then it was
uh then then finally we get that done
then covet hits so we have to wait
another year and then finally i just
said let's just put it out we just have
to get this out there
i don't want to wait any longer this
thing is ready
and uh saban the the company that
distributed and paramount
uh came through and decided to let me
put it out
over thanksgiving weekend which was huge
for us because it did really well
and it went number one right it did it
did
our little movie that could it really
was it was like this little movie
that went through so much you know so
many battles just to get it
across the finish line and then to see
it perform
i was literally in like in my car with
my son
i think it was i was taking him to
school and we were stopping at
mcdonald's i think to get like an egg
mcmuffin
that a year and and so
and i get a call from the head of the uh
jonathan saba over at saban
saying that we just got to number one
and i literally
i my eyes started welling up and i like
this tear my my son's like dad are you
okay this girl's like i know i'm okay
i'm good i'm good i'm good
we went number one he's like yeah you
will never
he doesn't know what that means but he
knew how much it meant to me
but it was one of those moments because
it was like this rush of just
i don't know what it was but when we you
know to know that we
at least were performing was a big deal
because
believe me i've had a weekend i've had
plenty of them that haven't done that
and sure you know so man that's so cool
i i it makes me sort of
i think about like the mental aspect and
the
manifesting aspect of life a lot
and what kind of creates your reality
and the one thing i kept thinking about
with your story
with this movie and it's your it's the
first one that you've
written and directed right that's also
amazing
congratulations um is this
power of belief and and and i
i i'm curious uh if you
felt like this was part of the magic or
what was the magic in finally getting it
made because
um i feel like there's some things in my
life that have happened where i'm like
the things that i just like
believed i don't know why like blind
faith on why something that something
was gonna work and then they do
under all odds and obstacles it still
happens and
um then there are other things that you
think are a no-brainer that don't and so
i feel like that's something that maybe
you had with this project and i'm
wondering
why you had that such a good question
because it's true i did have this belief
in this thing
and partly because i've seen it like i
said i'd seen it perform when we put it
in front of a bunch of people that were
just off the streets
and we had video of them just like
literally like
like curling over laughing i was like oh
my god they think it's
good they think it's funny they get my
sixth sense of humor
uh and so but i did but i believed in it
before that you know i've never i'd
always wanted to direct but i didn't
know
i didn't know if i had the ability to
you know lead a 100
100 crew members you know i didn't know
if i i knew that i could do it
but i didn't know if i like we said
before i didn't know if i knew enough
but i
then i realized i didn't have to know
everything but i knew that we made a
good movie i knew that we made a funny
movie and i believed in that much for
sure
it was just a matter of making sure that
we got somebody behind us that also felt
the same yeah and having somebody like
paramount having somebody like
saban helped me sort of at least get it
out there on a good weekend
where people were gonna be available
um it has so much to do with it because
if you don't have the right weekend or
if you're up against something that's
just going to crush everything else
it makes it hard because
you know this whole thing has been about
belief
and trusting that you know just buying
the thing back from the studio nobody
does i remember i
remember i told that i told my attorney
we're buying a i'm buying a bag he's
like okay you got the biggest balls i've
ever seen nobody's ever done that
but i felt like we had to do it because
i felt like it needed it needed
that and needed a real shot and you know
at the end of the day it's like if you
don't take
big swings you're not gonna ever you
know hit a home run
well that's something that clearly comes
through as i was sort of
reading and watching some videos and
things like that and
preparation to know some more details
about you and your life and
all the things you've been working on is
that it became really clear to me
how um
fearless is the word that i kept
thinking um
but um focused
or um
like almost like blinders like you just
seem like
there's an ability for you to just stay
focused on something until
um either something better comes along
or it happens
is this am i reading the situation well
yeah there's definitely i think that
there's i would say the same thing about
you by the way i mean
my goodness um but
yeah i i think that you in order to do
first of all i don't think you can have
a plan b
you have it has to be it has to be
success or nothing
and right and i i was going to be a
dentist i was going to go to dental
school i got my degree in biology and
after i sort of
you know you're gonna be a dentist left
that behind
i didn't have a plan b anymore it was
like okay so this is i don't
you know what if i don't if i don't make
it
i'm not gonna i don't know what else i'm
gonna do
um and so i never really had a plan b so
i had to figure out how to make it work
and um i remember peyton manning said
something about that one time he goes
you know i think he was a choice between
denver and
another team and they said how do you
know you made the right choice he goes
what if you make the wrong choice he
goes i'm not going to make the wrong
choice because i'm going to make this
choice work
and that's sort of that's sort of the
mentality that you have to have or that
i've had to have because
and i still do i don't have anything
else i have to make this work
and if you know if it's just purely out
of you know
desperation or fear or just blind belief
or
just stupidity uh
you know even on my first there was a i
was on all my children was my first job
as an actor and
i had no i had no business being on the
show because i had no i had no
experience and i felt like i'd faked my
way
onto this show and
my mom had watched soap operas my whole
life so i knew sort of what
what was expected or what kind of what
and i and i've been taking classes and
i've been doing i
it's not like i just like walked out
there and
but i was really green and i was
extremely nervous
and i just remember going okay so
i'm going to do this and i'm going to
make sure i'm going to make a splash and
i find
and i'm either going to sink or i'm
going to swim
and so i just tried [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] on
that show
that that people weren't really used to
and and it started to work and people
started to like take notice and that was
when i first said oh my god
and i still sometimes feel like i'm
faking it
or that i'm a big fraud or whatever but
it was
it was it's that you know
desperate um
i don't desperate the right word it's uh
it's a reckless sort of abandon that
mentality that i have that you just have
you gotta go for it you can't be afraid
and that was when how i got the first
job it was like
i i just literally had there was a scene
where i had to
lose i'd like like
it was like this he was screaming or
something and i remember i just lost it
you know when it was that moment when i
was like okay and i remember seeing the
casting director going
i could see them look in their eyes that
i got the job
and it was like letting go and just
being not afraid of looking stupid
anymore in an audition because i always
walked into these auditions thinking i
look like an idiot they're making fun of
me as soon as i leave
and that was uh you know that was kind
of when i
realized that you just gotta go for it
otherwise you're just gonna
half-ass it and never really
go anywhere i don't know if that makes
any sense yeah it totally makes sense
the two things that come to mind are
is that really you is that you the
reckless abandoned just go for it guy
and so i'm curious if that shows up in
your personal life
you know when you're riding snowmobiles
or something like that are you like yeah
let's just jump that who cares
or because it's the same thing with
buddy games and pushing the limit and
making it this extreme comedy that's
like
whether it's that or whether it's your
auditions it's like is that actually you
or are you um
is this sort of just like i don't know
is this is this like an
aspect where you are actually meeting a
flow state because there
there's also a dynamic of forcing things
versus flowing and when you kind of flow
and sort of let
like the natural sort of evolving
and path open up for you and it tends to
lead to really magical things
and really good places um but there's
always some effort
along the way that needs to be done so
it's this balancing act of forcing and
flowing
so is that where you actually reach your
flow state then where you kind of go i'm
just gonna let go whatever comes out
comes out
and so you have this like perfect
sort of actually it's really perfect
because you get things done you get in
the door
and then you allow yourself to be
vulnerable which is so rare so which one
i mean or maybe you're both maybe it's
both well no i think that's
god you're good at this you could be
like a you could be a therapist danica
i don't know this that uh
it is i mean i think that i've always
had this this
this sort of contrarian
sort of approach like i don't want to do
what other people are
i'm trying to do things that are
different because i feel like i've had
to sort of prove myself and other in
ways that
you know there's expect there's people
that expect a certain something for me
but i'm always trying to prove them
different
you know the people are always trying to
put you in some kind of a box
and you have to fight your way out of it
and that's where you're going to be
and
so i think that yes there it i there's a
lot of hard work that goes into finding
that flow state
i beat myself up i mean especially if
there's a
if we're for an as an example i guess
would if you got to get if there's a
scene where you have to be
uh like jupiter's legacy for example
because this is the new tv series that's
coming out in 2021 right yeah 2021 it'll
be out
um and there was the this character
loses his mind he loses he
is he's he witnesses his dad jump off
this building
after the crash in 29 and
uh starts to lose his mind
and like i don't know how to lose my
mind apparently i mean maybe i mean
maybe i
maybe maybe i'd have lost my mind i
don't know
but i had to get to this place and for
me to get there
i'm sure that there's there's proper
ways to do it there's you know if i
could have gone up you know like
juilliard or something they would have
taught me this is how you actually get
there
but i had to figure it out on my own i
had to figure out okay so i had to work
myself
into this place that was so like you
don't want to be around me when i'm do
it's not because i have to like
literally lose my mind for that
seven hours on set and
or at least be able to be close to it so
i can jump back in and out of it between
setups or takes or whatever and so
i would i learned this early on too i
just had to like
beat myself into a place that i got that
i felt like i was
there and then when i was there i was
able to flow
because i couldn't just i couldn't
pretend it i had to actually
be it i had to be that you know i had to
be this crazy person for this amount
for the for this it was like two
episodes of the show
and it was it's exhausting and i
remember you know it was just so hard to
go home from work just exhausted and
like
[Music]
so it's it's it's either
therapeutic or it's really damaging i
don't know
it's one of the two well it depends on
what you had to think of to make
yourself go crazy
yeah what did you have to think of to
make yourself go crazy i don't know
uh
[Music]
yeah i don't know i don't know i don't
remember i'm kind of kind of black out
when i think about it
i i mean for me i i had this experience
just the other day i was talking to my
therapist and
something triggered me and then i was
distracted while she was talking and she
could see i was and
i almost didn't tell her and then sure
enough the next thing that happened
there's a message that comes in and it
comes across my computer because it pops
up on the side
and then i thought of that being
something bad too and all of a sudden i
realized i spiraled real quick and it
has never happened with her before but
it was a really interesting moment to
observe
how quickly i realized how quickly
getting to a certain mindset and
state of mind thought process
put me there for everything all of a
sudden
everything was everything was an attack
everything was dangerous everything was
threatening in some kind of a way to my
happiness
and i wonder like as that being an
example
i wonder how it goes for an
actor because i work really hard to stay
happy
and not have those moments um
but you guys you guys do that for a
living
and
what's the repercussions of that well i
first of all i think that what you
do or did for for many years
was took far more focus than what what
anything i've ever done
yet you know i feel like i have to be
hyper focused just to stay in that place
just to just to you know so i don't
because if anything hits me and i get
out of it then i'm like i'm screwed
i gotta like stay in this spot while i'm
you know for the for the for the
duration of at least this scene then
i'll
go out of it for a little bit and come
back in but
i mean i think you would understand that
more than anybody the amount of focus
the
hyper focus that it takes to stay
you know yeah in it and be able to like
to drive a car that fast and to not you
know
kill yourself i mean you're i mean i'm
just on the set you're in a car going
100
whatever how many miles an hour did you
go a couple
couple i mean probably everybody always
wants to know i mean i
i mean 200 was very normal yeah indy
cars probably more of a top speed of
like 240 at indy but
stock cars was maybe like i don't know
top speed of maybe more like 225
right indycars or what
more like 240 tops yeah
yeah i do i don't do you know that i
drove the the pace car
oh where was that
hang on that was recently i'd have to
look i think it was like 2 000
a couple years ago nine oh wasn't it
it was a while ago it was 2009 or 11. i
don't
but i got to see first because i'm not a
fast driver i'm not like i'm not a guy
that's out there
tearing up the streets so for me to go
into the corner like that
at that speed was terrifying because i
was like there's no way the car is going
to hold
and then and then you know i'm just
driving the pace car working my way up
to i think the 120 is the highest we got
or maybe 140.
and then those just fly right past you
going 240 miles an hour like i'm
standing still
and that's when i realized that these
people are a different
breed to be able to get in those cars
i'm gonna cont i mean i'm gonna contest
that because what i was gonna draw a
parallel between was that you
i asked you what you did to get into
that state of
rage and anger and go crazy
um and you said i don't really remember
and what i thought of was how when we're
at the when i was be at the track
and i would meet people and then see
them again
and i'd be like hi and i made the
mistake way too many times going oh nice
to meet you they go i already met you
before
and then after enough times of them
telling me that they met me at the
racetrack
i had to tell them i was like oh if i
met you at the racetrack i don't
remember that
very much because you're not all there
right so it's a different brain state
you're in a different state it's an
altered state so i don't think that it's
now look are you going to die on set
less likely than in a race car
yeah but it doesn't mean that you aren't
accessing a different space
and that might be what makes it easier
to flip the switch on and off
is that it isn't you yeah
and that's part of the beauty of it by
the way that's why i love it is i get to
go like
wow it gets it i get it it gets into the
you get to go crazy you get to access
being different
because you you like being different
i get to yeah i get to go pretend for a
living i need to go
you know i get to do things that i would
never be allowed to do in real life
they would literally put me in in a in a
rubber room you know or a padded room
they would put me away
in and that's you know you get to in
whether it's
you know playing this guy who loses his
mind for
you know a period of time or getting to
play goat farmer or getting to play
you know lieutenant whatever it is
it's just a different you get to like
lose yourself and there's a freedom in
that
you know and and you don't have to be
you
for a while and it's kind of fun not
having to be you what has been
some of the more like [ __ ] up
sort of roles or
characters that you've been able to be
where you did it
and then afterwards you were like god
that felt so cool to be that person for
a hot second
oh man um
there i mean there's a lot of times when
it's really exhilarating and fun and a
little scary that it is actually
exhilarating and fun because
that's what i mean which ones which ones
well
it depends on i mean they're all
everything is different every that's
another reason i love
getting to do this is every job is a
different adventure everyone's
it's a different you know journey and so
i remember getting there was a i did a
show called 11 22 63. it was a
hulu show about it was a stephen king
book based on this the
assassination of jfk and how this guy
goes back james franco actually goes
he goes finds his wormhole in this diner
and it takes him back to the same point
in time
every time he goes back it's always the
same spot and anyway
he tries to go back and stop this dude
from from hurting one of his students
like his student is now he's
actually he's a he's a he's a janitor at
the school that he teaches at he does
like these after school sort of
um education classes and this guy is
mentally
not there because of what his dad did to
him all those years ago when he goes
back through he tries to stop that his
dad from doing that to his
son he was a murderer drunken like
rage and i was that guy and
easily probably the most messed up
character i've ever played because this
guy was
the worst like the worst kind of human
but it was kind of fun to play it
because i was just like oh god it's
like nobody's ever cast me to play this
dude and it was
you know he was a terrible human being
and i don't know if i had so much fun in
it but i found there i found it
it's interesting to like live that
for a little bit you know it's like whoa
like you got to be pretty [ __ ] up to
do what this guy did
and for me like i said before i have to
go into that space and actually believe
that i'm
this dude and and it was
crazy i mean another thing i just i just
did finish this thing in mexico city
this movie called blackout
we finish it this week here but
it's about this guy that blacks out he
gets in this car accident
completely he wakes up and doesn't
remember who he is doesn't remember
anything he
gives him something happened to his head
and
he really when he wakes up he realizes
that he has all these abilities to like
kick ass and you know he's got he
handles guns and he does
he was like a badass
and there was a scene where this this
one this this
this mexican uh cartel thug dude is
after me and we get this big fight we're
in this kitchen
i end up breaking this plate and
stabbing him in the neck a bunch of
times and even
we had like this rubber thing and they
had this fake blood and i remember just
going there and just doing it i was like
and after we were done with the scene
like after he he
they yelled cut i remember just like
having flood
i had like this flood of um emotion like
[ __ ] can you imagine i could never
ever do that because i felt like i had
just actually done that to that dude
there's blood all over my hands and it
was just this weird
so space okay so
there's a con this bear with me for a
second this concept of we're all part of
the same hole
right we're all part of the same hole
and uh jordan peterson is coming to mind
how he
speaks about um you know the monster in
you and
you know things like that and so
understanding that we're all part of the
same whole
and that that would mean that every
aspect
of a personality is sort of within each
of us
doesn't mean it's who we are normally
doesn't mean we access it
but now thinking about that
it kind of gives me some insight into
acting and how people can get there
because
those aspects live in you just as they
live in me
but an actor learns how to access them
yeah is there any role is there any role
when you do get there when you go to a
place that you could do something like
he only does he does it out of
self-defense but he does it it's pretty
brutal how he ends up having to take
this guy out
and i just remember like sitting there
like everybody left
the set it was just me sitting there and
i couldn't like
i couldn't like get it back together i
was just like
overcome by this thing it was weird oh
you had to like come down from it you
had to
you experience the real emotion yeah
which is a real thing in fact your body
doesn't know the difference between that
being a truth or a lie
doesn't know that you haven't
experienced it
doesn't know that it was work and it was
fake it just
has the feeling and that is real just
like if you wanted to
um just like the power of belief of the
film being made buddy games like you
you believed it you could see it made
you
you
envisioned it you you burst that thing
like it was real because you saw it
and so your body doesn't know that it
hasn't
like your reality it it it manifested it
because he didn't know that it wasn't
real
you saw it as if it was you felt it as
if it was
so in those moments where you're like
stabbing someone to death
you just had to deal with stabbing
someone to death because your body can't
tell that that didn't really happen
because you felt the real emotion of
it wow that's kind of jacked up i know
it's messed up
now you know why we're all so crazy yeah
i do
yeah totally like you guys are like
uh you're like chameleons you're like um
wow that's that's fascinating that's a
really interesting unpack of an actor
have you ever have you ever heard uh do
you ever do you were talking about
um i feel like you probably have heard
of this like oprah and deepak's
21 day meditation i've heard of that
yeah
there's one there's one um
i'd do them like a i'll sit at lunch and
i'll just like listen to them just to
sort of like
send out for 20 minutes one that talks
about what you're talking about it's
called effortless creation
and it's there's several of them but
this one's called the energies of
the energy of attraction and each one of
this each one of the days has a
different story and this one in
particular is called
effortless creation so it's all about
it's all about like doing the work doing
the work doing the work
and then letting it go like for me i'd
always try to hold on so tight and make
things happen but then when i realized
that there's only so much you can do and
you just got to let the universe take
over
that was kind of the way i had to
like look at the getting body games made
is just do the work
and trust that it's gonna trust that
it's gonna you know happen the right way
and sometimes it doesn't sometimes it
doesn't but you know that was luckily
one of the ones that
did were there any things that you
can think of that you know you you
you strangled to death like you hung
onto something so hard that
because the idea would be that if you
want something so badly that there is
um an equal amount of energy that you
think you're not going to get it which
is why you want it so bad
right you're grasping so hard
with the fear that it's not going to
happen so essentially you sort of negate
that and
you negate the energy to make it um
is there anything you feel like in your
life where you've been like oh you know
what
i i i that i got in my own way there
or like i blocked the flow i hung on to
that so long and i shouldn't have
that's yeah i've done that many times i
mean
i think that we probably all have
and and it's it's if you can
figure out how to get past that and
sometimes you can sometimes you can't
but that's one thing
like listening to that particular one
really helped me go you know what
she's right i just have to trust that
you know if you do the work and if you
and if your intentions are if you set
that intention and do the work to do it
there's a certain point you just gotta
let it go and just trust that it's gonna
happen or it's not
and that was you know it's hard to let
it go
you know especially when you're i mean
i'm a
somebody who has a hard time like i like
to like force things to happen but i'm
starting to learn how to just kind of
just trust
and just do it and if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't
and either way it's gonna be fine yeah
and that's
an easy thing to say until you have to
get into the moment of letting something
go and you're like yeah
[Laughter]
so i always feel like for me like i i
don't know i i
have a really easy time letting go of
work stuff but when it comes to like
relationships
i'm a real grasper and um is there
do you see this show up more so like are
you easy breezy in certain aspects of
your life and then other ones you're
like man you kind of really
you put almost all your energy into it
and it tends to be the one that's got
the most amount of
issues yeah i mean i'm i'm probably like
you and that i hold on i mean
i put i mean i think that's the perfect
way to the perfect example is in
relationships sometimes you want
something to work out so badly that you
do everything and ultimately you just
[ __ ] it up by
trying too hard and then we don't try as
hard it seems like it just comes
so it's like finding that balance
between okay well so i
how do i do this and how do i do this so
i'm not
first of all it's not codependent i want
it to feel like this needs to be like a
two-way street
you know it needs to feel like you know
we're equally we're equals
apart and we're stronger when we're
together that's another thing that's
hard
that's another i mean we i could go on
and on about this stuff but
i've i've been broken enough
as enough times to like
maybe not hold on so tight and just sort
of let it happen
because maybe partly because i just
don't want to be broken again
um and
so i don't know how healthy that is but
it's i think it's some sort of a
protective mechanism
i don't know go play that character in a
movie
you'll figure something out right go
play the really really
super needy attached boyfriend
who you know or play the detached guy
play the anxious avoidant detached guy
that like
you know can't commit for the life of
him and um doesn't care
and plays the field and then maybe he'll
start to sort of like understand
the balance maybe hey we should write it
it's a good idea
okay i mean i i'd actually be far more
interested
in the writing and more so that and the
directing than maybe the acting even
it's like this guy's a
he's both a love attract he's a love
addict and a love avoidant at the same
time
[Laughter]
he loves the avoidance yes
i don't know or they're two separate
movies you know or their split
personality yeah there you go
what if you had a split personality
character that was like one was a
codependent the other was avoidant
that would be the most mind-blowing con
let's not do that that's going to mess
people up do you feel like you've
learned
i mean have you learned some lessons
about yourself through acting and being
these
you know like sort of just
stuff about yourself you're like man i
didn't really know that i'd enjoy that
so much or i didn't know that i actually
kind of like i you know what that i
don't allow myself to be like that
enough i should
um i want to say
yes but
and i think i think that's probably
that's probably true i mean i think you
can't
you can't help but to learn
to learn about yourself through
the eyes of a different person or at
least
be able to compare the two like okay i
would never do that or
i should do more of that um
but am i able to sort of apply it to my
real life i don't know
um i don't know i'll have to get back to
you on that one
which character has been the most to you
the most me
that character in 11 22 63 no i'm
kidding
i would say i would say the uh
the most me would maybe maybe mess her
from
life as we know it somebody did with
katie heigl many years ago
i don't know i think there's a little
bit of me in all of it you know you have
to
it you have to you have to
you know put enough of you out there but
also
have the fun of sort of finding
uh finding aspects of you that
aren't really there and you got to find
them i don't know
i would but i would say messer probably
has someone giving you like what's the
best advice someone gave you
along the way when it came to acting oh
god that's such a good question
um i remembered he didn't actually tell
me this could have never worked but i
remember that
tom hanks said that just hit your mark
and tell the truth
you know and i think that that's really
at the end of the day people
watching anything know if you're telling
the truth or not and they can tell they
can
they can tell if you're acting from a
mile away so i've always just tried to
find the actual the absolute truth
in it whatever whatever scene whatever
character whatever
you know project just tell the truth
uh that's probably
that'd probably be it
did anyone give you some terrible advice
at any point that you're like
yeah that guy was an [ __ ]
like an agent telling you to take a roll
and you're like that was the worst idea
ever
i mean i just i don't remember anybody
giving me bad advice
uh but i remember i remember i would
i always know that i was doing so i did
a show called las vegas for
like five years particularly yeah i
remember that one
i remember that early 2000s that's right
that's where i discovered you
i was like who's that guy oh really uh
well anyway
so it was jimmy it was james kahn
and he was he you know he's a legend the
dude is like godfather and
a million other things my son now knows
him from elf from
elf oh buddy the elf it's on all day
every day right now
uh but i always knew that i was that i
wasn't
that was doing something wrong or
something i could do be doing good
because he'd be like josh come over here
for a second
anyway and i was like here comes the
kind of you know he'd tell me he you'd
say you'd walk it too like
just relax or just you know you don't
have to trust whatever it was he would
he was not afraid to give me
advice and i took it because
he's james khan and
and i still this day if anybody's got a
better idea i'll take it um
try not to get too caught up in
in what you know
you know what i believe it is supposed
to be somebody's got a better idea i
think that you know
it'll it'll help me why not
[Music]
so he gave you some good advice then oh
yeah
i mean always i mean it was it was
uncomfortable most
of the time but yeah that's where the
growth
you know it's like it's like it's like
getting taken you know it's like the
principle of calling you into his office
saying oh god here we go need to take me
back to you know where there's nobody
around and you
start talking about the scene and how
you know you know maybe not do that so
much or maybe
maybe a little bit more whatever it was
but i was just yeah
again i was that was early on i was
right after all my children and
i probably needed it
everything shows up right on time that's
right even if it's difficult shows up
right on time when you need it
um so if you were to kind of like
wave a magic wand and create
your dream movie goal situation
show like is there something out there
that you're like man this is this is
this is what i still want to do
i don't know i mean i never
i never really know what i'm gonna what
i want to do until i read it
until i see it but
if i'm i mean i know the types of people
that i want to work with i know the
the kinds of projects that i want to be
a part of
you know it's like dream it up and then
let it go yeah
set your intention let it go just let it
go
let it go let it flow
i'm super happy for you congrats on
number one movie first ever time that
you'd written and directed
i mean what would you you know i'd love
to ask people this
at the end um that uh you know i'd love
to under
love to get your take
on whatever your greatest life lesson
has been
i just think this is so helpful for
people oh god
okay um
my dad's given me a couple great ones
okay
one he said find a woman who
sees the world
from an optimistic point of view she's
the world who sees the world
glass half full
[Music]
um and find a girl who loves her father
because she doesn't love her dad she
probably won't love you but the most
important
one that he ever said was this is when i
first bought my
the first part of my property at the at
the lake
he said uh we had the first thing i ever
bought was this floating dock
and it was the only thing we had out
there we didn't have a boat we didn't
have a cab we have anything
and and we just were able to like take
this trail back through this to this
point
and we had this little dock out there
and it was early in the spring and the
water was free like barely
just had thawing out so it's freezing
cold and i was
just dying to jump in this lake because
i had my first
day so i was like i don't want to
[ __ ]
do it he's like come on be a brave soul
and i still remember him saying that be
a brave soul
and that is i mean that's like really
good
advice you know i tell my son that now i
was like
coming if he's like afraid of something
i don't think he should be
be a brave soul you know what i think
i bet you have some dreams for your
personal life i bet that's
maybe that is where you focus your
thoughts and efforts and ideas am i
am i off on that
what do you mean like you know have a
family have more kids get married live
in
minnesota tran you know this is where
i'll be
this is the kind of you know we'll do
these things we're gonna snowmobile and
then we're gonna go
fishing and then we're gonna like maybe
i don't know i'm curious is that maybe
an area of your life that you do
really dream into oh yeah for sure i
mean
that's my life yeah my life isn't my
life isn't
my work my life is my life um
you know and if my life is good
the rest will follow i mean it's
you know it's like if you if you're
happy it's only going to help your work
it's only going to help all our
other aspects and you know i'm working
on that sometimes i'm happy sometimes
i'm
frustrated with the world um sometimes
you've just murdered someone in a scene
and you're off
yeah and i'm just trying to just trying
to come down from that you know
hey were any people injured in the
filming of buddy games
yes damn back at all
dan bakker actually got really hurt he
there's just there's this big when you
watch it and i know you're gonna go
watch it
i am there there's a there's a there's
this big giant
slide that's at the end of this obstacle
course
that i had them make it was like we
couldn't believe we actually got them to
build it because it was the most
expensive
part of the movie pretty much and
so you know it's this big slide that
goes down and then it's supposed to kick
and then
and then shoot up well it just went down
and then sort of kicked
too quick well he went down this thing
feet first and started sliding sideways
and as he was hitting the side of it
that caught hit his leg on the side of
it
and got what they call a subdermal
hematoma and
literally to this day this is three
years later if not more
he still has a mark on his leg from his
like almost worse than a broken leg
because he literally so we had to sit
him down and stand him up between each
take like he
he should we shouldn't have been able to
finish the movie because it happened
exactly halfway
through the movie so we literally had to
body double him and put him back up and
sit him down and lay him you know and
and he was completely disabled
for half of the movie so thank god he
was such a stud
and and fought through it otherwise we
wouldn't have had the movie
you had some real athletes out there huh
oh yeah i mean
nick schwartzen is nothing if not an
athlete
speaking of athletes uh do the vikings
need any more fans because
i'm up for grabs oh yeah we'll take it
we'll take you come back come back from
the dark side danica
we need you over here all right well
thank you so much all right
um and good luck with uh jupiter's
legacy too
thank you so much you're really good at
this that was fun
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button